i wonder if you can try your hand at
this i'll give you a nudge and then i'll
see if i can get on your own
okay they give you another vector
equation but it's rather more exotic
you're like whoa
cosines and sines what are they doing in
there don't worry don't freak out the
question will explain
you've got a vector equation and then
they've given you particular values for
vector a vector b vector c
okay the question itself part a says
show that this is a circle
i wonder which part of you might think
oh i can see why that might be a circle
right we can show that it's a circle by
finding the cartesian equation now just
have a look at how we kind of did
something similar here
right to try and get towards an equation
you're going to
combine different things together and
then remember i had to get out of vector
form see how this is
in vectors right this is a vector
equation and then suddenly by
this point i'm now talking about
parameters you see that okay
now what you're going to do is something
very similar using these vector
distances right
vector distances take you from vector
notation to
non-vector notation you see that's where
we made the transition so you're going
to need this point here that's why i've
highlighted it so you've got it there in
red then part b
where on the circle is theta equals zero
on the unit circle which i unhelpfully
rubbed off on the unit circle we know
where theta equals zero is where is it
where do we measure from zero we start
from like twelve o'clock that's how we
measure on a clock
don't know me guys theta equals zero on
the unit circle where is it
it's a it's the positive real axis
that's what we measure things from
right that was a test to see if you're
awake you failed that's okay
um theta because zero is on the positive
real axis and then we go
anti-clockwise right on this circle
where is theta equals zero on this and
then as you add on to theta
do you go anti-clockwise or do you go
the other way you're only going to know
by trying out some different values of
theta so that's where this question goes
i'm gonna give you a five or ten minute
head start to see how far you can get
my big clue for you is this is the
crucial step that's a bit tricky and
weird
right how do i get from vector stuff to
get out of vector stuff that's what they
mean when they say
find its cartesian equation you need to
make use of this okay
have a go and i'll come together with a
solution
afterwards if you have trouble let us
know
all right so uh let's try and bring this
together um it's been really encouraging
by the way seeing many of you
totally on the money few arithmetic
errors who snuck in and i'm going to
show you a way to try and avoid some of
them right
let's have a look at this first line
that i've written okay
what is this first line this first line
is the vector equation of this mystery
thing which apparently turns out to be a
circle
all i've done is i've replaced the v the
a
the b and the c right a b and c are
given
so one two three and then v is just
shorthand four
there's an x component there's a y
component because i'm in two dimensions
here
okay now the reason why it's helpful for
me to do that is because
once you've got everything in column
form
column form can interact with column
form yeah
so i've got three vectors over here on
the right hand side
which i know is going to be messy if i
try and do this vector distance business
right not impossible
just messy whereas now if i
say for example subtract 0 2 from both
sides
you can see what am i getting over here
i've got an x and a y minus 2
pretty easy to do pythagoras on that and
by the same token over here
in fact that doesn't need any change at
all i'm just going to leave it
as is so at this point i'm going to use
this vector distance idea here it's just
pythagoras in here to do this right
i've got a distance it's two hypotenuses
as it were
except i'm comparing them on both sides
so what do we get
should be x squared plus y minus two all
squared
yes which is just delightful isn't it
this already is in kind of the form that
i want right
equals to now yeah you have a look right
you're like oh as i expand this out
you got a cos squared and a sine squared
this will also give you a cos squared
and a sine squared
and then when you do the minus 2 a b
what do you get on the first on the x
component
minus 2 sine theta cos theta for this
one you get
plus 2 sine sine theta cos theta so of
course you would actually write this out
by the interest of you actually getting
out of here without watching me write
seven lines okay
you're gonna get two and then it's well
there is a cos squared plus a sine
squared right i've factored it out we
got one from
each line okay so in fact this being one
right just to make it very very obvious
right what is this 2
it's root 2 or squared see i've got a
cartesian equation now does this make
sense so that's an r squared
do not fall into that little trap
because we've been
because we've been looking at equations
like say for instance
this which has a radius of three right
and then you go over to the cartesian
world and you're like whoa wait that's
an r squared
not an r right so it's a bit like the
first time you learnt
integration you're like a
differentiation integration my brain's
getting all mixed up and confused
because you've got both of them together
it's kind of a similar thing here we see
students do it all the time
radius two no radius root two okay
so we have succeeded this is a circle we
found its cartesian equation
part b read the wording with me because
there's some weird words we don't tend
to use very frequently
where on the circle is theta equals zero
and in which direction
is the circle traversed as
theta increases what does traverse mean
you can in this context i could use the
word rotate
because it's a circle um but in fact
traverse is a lot more general than that
i could for example say go back to
i don't have one on the board i could go
back to some straight line
right i think the one we were looking at
before was something like this i might
have my ones and twos upside down
i can say that as lambda increases
lambda is the parameter here
i traverse this line does that make
sense i move from one
end to the other so traversal can mean
rotation as it does here but it doesn't
have to
okay where does it land you when you put
in uh it's not lambda it's
theta right when you put in theta equals
zero where do you end up
one you get you get a vector right of
uh one one yes now it will help you here
to have
even a rough sketch and i hope you've
already got one actually show of hands
who's got
the diagram on their page oh come on
you're 12.
we've taught them nothing mrs liz okay
get your ruler out draw me a set of axes
okay you can do this with me it's not
even hard right it's a circle with
center what
it's a circle with center what zero two
so
zero one two bam there's the center
right
the radius we've already established is
root 2 root 2 is roughly
1.4 right so if this is 1 then 1.4 is
about there
should have been further up sorry and
about
there there's my distance vertically i'm
going to do the same thing
horizontally and there we go look mine a
pair of compasses
you can do one at least as good as that
there's my circle
where is one one
halfway down i put even a scale for
myself right it looks like it must be
about there
that's not too bad free handed it right
so there's one one
which is theta equals zero and now i
need to work out well
as theta gets bigger which way do i go
right now it's in our interest just to
choose a convenient value what might be
a nice convenient value
how about 90 degrees or pi on two when
you go ahead
and pop it back into here let's just see
what happens right you got zero two
what happens to cos theta when theta
equals pi on two
zero it's zero that's why it appears in
the
dot product right because when they're
orthogonal you get no dot product we'll
get dot product of zero
so you've got here we go you've got this
term disappearing
what happens to sine theta when theta is
pound two it's one so you're just
getting
this zero two plus this negative one
negative one
what's that give you negative one
one where is that on my circle
symmetrical to the uh by the
way very good symmetrical across the
y-axis thank you so
here's theta equals pi on two
sorry that's horrendously messy okay so
you can see which way i'm rotating which
way am i rotating
clockwise like so there's the center
and there's that pie on two okay and if
you wanted be overkill but you could put
more angles in and you'd get it
okay does this make sense